la parole est maintenant notre collègue
charles guené pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
s'adressèrent monsieur le ministre des
finances et des comptes publics
si on lis votre projet de loi de
finances prévoit un déficit budgétaire
de 3,3 pour cent en 2016
vous maintenez que la france se rend
dessous des 3% exigés par les critères
de convergence de la zone euro en 2017
avec 2 7% de déficit
faut-il s'attendre à de nouvelles
hausses de prélèvements quand on sait
que la dépense publique
loin d'être maîtrisés a crû de 0 9% en
volume en 2015
le gouvernement s'est engagé à limiter
la hausse de la dépense publique à 0,3
pour cent en volume en 2016
mais vous ne l'expliqué pas même le
rapporteur général du budget socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale dénonce que plus
de la moitié des économies de dépenses
de l'état prévue en 2016 ne sont pas ou
peu documentée à ce rythme les déficits
seraient en 2010 est de 3,9 pour cent
c'est d'ailleurs ce que semble justifier
les réserves de bruxelles qui ne croient
pas en leurs prévisions la commission
européenne vous situe aux environs de 3
3 % en 2017 quand vous annoncez le
chiffre de 2 7%
monsieur le ministre comment expliquez
vous un tel décalage
chaque année entre vos prévisions et la
réalité ne craignez-vous pas que nous
perdions toute crédibilité aux yeux de
nos partenaires européens pour nous
répondre la parole à jean marie le guen
après des recherches sur l'échec de
parents vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre à bout merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
en guinée tout d'abord je charge un
parent dont on parle
je t'ai troublé par savais pas je vous
trouve et où je me disais vous voyez ce
n'est pas la première fois et donc je
voulais tout d'abord excusé l'absence de
michel sapin être christian eckert qui
sont retenus à l'assemblée par le débat
budgétaire vous avez monsieur le
sénateur interpellé le rapport de la
commission européenne qui s'est produit
il ya environ une semaine et qui était
d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble des états
membres de l'union européenne
vous savez que la commission européenne
a constaté comme le gouvernement le
retour progressif de la croissance liée
au soutien de la consommation mais aussi
à la reprise de l'investissement et elle
a validé les chiffres du gouvernement de
déficit en 2015 comme en 2007 c'est à
dire un déficit qui d'ailleurs depuis
que nous sommes en responsabilité ne
cesse de décroître par rapport à ce qui
existait précédemment
il sera je vous le confirme de 3,8 et
oui messieurs c'est l'internât mais les
sénatrices 3,8 en 2015 3,4 en 2016 et
donc vous me posez aussi la question de
ce qui se passera en 2010 est puisque
effectivement la commission doit prendre
en compte la le troisième volet du plan
de diminution de dépenses publiques plan
de diminution de 50 milliards il restera
donc un volet de 15 milliards à mettre
en oeuvre pour 2017 qui explique que
nous serons effectivement en 2017 dans
ce que nous avons prévu c'est à dire un
déficit qui sera en dessous des 3%
voilà monsieur le sénateur les éléments
qui tend dans la vérification de ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois ans depuis deux
ans notamment puisque toutes nos prêts
conclus qu'il s'agisse de croissance ou
de déficit ont été respectées voilà le
plan de marche du gouvernement qui je
vous le confiant mettra notre pays sous
la barre des 3 % en 2017
on a rappelé que charles guené je vous
ai entendu monsieur le ministre mais
permettez moi un ferme à tim du pouvoir
socialiste engagement numéro 9 du
programme présidentiel le déficit public
sera réduit à 3% du pib en 2013
il a été de 4,1 pour cent michel sapin
14 avril 2014
il faut qu'il y ait 3 % de déficit en
2015 le déficit est estimé à 3 8 %
manuel valls 15 avril 2014 nous deux
nous tiendrons tous nos engagements
c'est la parole la crédibilité de la
france qui sont en jeu et personne ne
peut les mettre en doute
quant à pierre moscovici je cite dans la
zone euro seule la france l'espagne et
la grèce devrait connaître des déficits
supérieurs à 3% du pib en 2016 comment
voulez vous dans ces conditions monsieur
le ministre que la parole de la france
puisse continuer d'être crédible merci